when you were writing baby steps how
confident were you that you were going
to get the movie made again I wasn't
really focusing on not getting in made I
I knew I was again I keep using this
this like this meta not a metaphor but
like a reference like you were fool you
just keep walking and marching foolish
listeners you know foolishly without
like thinking about what's gonna happen
you just keep marching I just knew that
it would be made one day and I their
time can we're almost gave up but I
didn't having that that faith that
foolish face for some reason just kept
you going I remember one time after a
year of fundraising casting we were
going nowhere wonder the producers I was
working with left the project she spent
a year with me and we were going nowhere
so even after having raised about like
$300,000 of money
she left the project and I was like oh
what do I do you know I was swimming and
I was like should I give up
after eight after spending three years
writing and then one year fundraising -
what give up and do something else or -
I continued and I continued and that
evening like I talked to one of the
actors they did the actors that play the
mother character and that's when she
introduced me to her longtime
collaborator of Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon and because of that she picked it
up and the film got made so I guess I
was just like I never really I never not
getting the film a was never an option
and you just have to be a fool just keep
going before you said there were two
times she almost gave up were you able
to show the other time
that was that was a time oh is what okay
I mean that's pretty devastating well I
mean like there were so many times like
the ovens gave up because you know I
went through a year of casting the lead
character with the a-list names but
every time someone you know gives a pass
always a pass so I worry a little a
little bit you know a little bit of you
you know start questioning it but then
you just have to be a fool and just
don't think about it and just keep
marching foolishly foolish fate I like
to call it what was it about this film
that you had to make it it is so
personal and it was a dialogue if I
didn't make this movie my mother would
never be able to know how I feel about
us again I make this movie to connect
with my mother I there are so many
things I could not tell her in person
something about the Asian culture that
stops you from communicating person to
person with emotional stuff we don't
tell each other I love you we express
our ideas through actions and me I
express my ideas of frustration or
struggles conflicts through my writing
so I really wanted to make this movie so
my mother could see the film
my mother crude could read a screenplay
and see the finished product out on the
screen and understand how I felt and so
the film in a way connected us
emotionally and we went through this
journey together and this art really
helped riched our distance so on a
personal level that was very that was
that was a very important reason for me
to get the movie made having invested so
much my time on the project it's also
about an interracial couple - it's not
just same-sex marriage it's it's an
interracial relationship as well so
you're really challenging there's so
many I mean like one of the things that
we screenwriters think about is were
this like multiple levels of conflict in
this movie there's conflict between
mother
son a gay son and the mother who does
shameful about having gaze on there's
conflict between two vertical culture
the mother character is not very
accepting of the interracial
relationship there's conflict of global
conflicts there's no the couple is it's
like has no money how can they possibly
have a baby they the traditional way the
surrogacy in the u.s. macaws like one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars but
going through this global journey
somewhere else it's much cheaper so
there's economic class conflict there's
international conflict there's a supply
sub character an Indonesian housekeeper
in Taipei so there's there's ensure
there's class conflict in in in in this
subplot as well so there's like many
different levels of conflict that
screenwriters drive and create because
that's what makes a story interesting
and compelling right conflict conflict
conflicts which part was more of a hot
button the interracial or the same sex I
think it's the same sex marriage not the
marriage necessary but the coming to
terms with having a gay son having a gay
member of a family being open about it
it's very easy for Tony's culture or
parents to just not talk about that get
the gay aspect of your child's life you
know face is very important just having
a face you know oh yeah you know my son
is do well he's he's a filmmaker he went
just great school but not about the key
aspect of it so so yeah so not that was
definitely the major conflict of the
story the not being able to deal with
the gay aspect of the son's life so know
being in the Bay Area and I know you
were there for four years or whatever
and
having basically grown up there I saw so
many interracial relationships it seems
like it's pretty embraced there I found
it wasn't embraced as much in LA do you
notice that I realize that's a pretty
strong statement but I I really see that
the Bay Area was very open to
interracial not just same-sex couples
obviously but and I just think there's a
renaissance
in reclaiming pride for our own culture
growing up in America all the stuff you
see on the media what's beautiful white
is beautiful I've never seen images of
myself on a screen or prints or media
I've never seen a beautiful Asian man
so a lot of times you see a lot of
interracial couple Asian white black
white Hispanic white it's always it's a
manifestation of why it's beauty and
it's because of the media sure but right
now I think there's people of color we
are reclaiming our own beauty we see
more images of ourselves in the media so
I'm dating an Asian American man whereas
before I was dating like you know white
days so so maybe that's part of it I'm
not sure but definitely there's a
renaissance in our own pride own culture
and we're embracing that aspect that's
that has been missing in our
asian-american culture I feel like
Millennials have been instrumental in
that and Gen Z whereas maybe Generation
X wasn't as much and then baby boomers
but I feel like the newer generations
have been much more open to choosing a
different path whatever that is I mean I
think it's not the first diversity you
see so many different images now on TV
on film so it definitely feels more
inclusive so you definitely see myself
on screen now more representation now so
I think younger generation they don't
even think about what we think about
we're
yeah it's a given everybody's
everybody's everywhere
sure or a different and and also to
within the LGBT community there's just
excuse me LGBTQ community because they
added the queue recently right it wasn't
always that right what is the reason for
that curious what's the queer
designation I think there's the idea of
there's so many different again to the
idea the community is not monolithic
less LGBTQ it sort of encompasses
everything else that's not there's
there's gender non-binary there's
transgender and within the community
attention of the community there's
diversity the people that are
questioning we're not sure so it
encompasses everything else interesting
that are marginalized right
you